هبطت طائرات شحن عسكرية روسية
في العاصمة التركية
يوم الجمعة لتسليم الدفعة الأولى من نظام
الدفاع الصاروخي الروسي AS / 400
ومعها ضربة قوية
لعلاقة تركيا المهتزة بالفعل مع
حليفتها في الناتو أمريكا ، ولم يكن هناك
سرًا بشأن وصول S400
تم بث صور حية على وسائل الإعلام التركية
حيث تباهت وزارة الدفاع بعملية الاستحواذ الجديدة
منذ شهور ، وكانت الولايات المتحدة
تضغط على أنقرة لإلغاء
اتفاقها مع روسيا.
إنهم قلقون من أن
روسيا يمكن أن تستخدم s400 لجمع البيانات
عن الطائرة المقاتلة الشبح ليس فقط
لأن تركيا لا تزال تنتظر تسليم
حوالي مائة طائرة من طراز F-35 ، بل إنها
تصنع أيضًا حوالي 900 جزء من الطائرة
ولكن خطر الطرد من الطائرة
برنامج f-35 والعواقب الوخيمة
بما في ذلك العقوبات الاقتصادية التي
ستضر بالاقتصاد الهش لهذا البلد
لم يردع المسؤولين الأتراك عن قول ذلك
الأمر يتعلق بالسيادة ، وهذا يتعلق
بحق تركيا في الدفاع عن نفسها
، كما ألقى المسؤولون باللوم على الولايات المتحدة.
لعرقلة جهود الديوك الرومية لشراء
نظام الدفاع الصاروخي الأمريكي باتريوت ،
لكن الرسائل المختلطة من
الولايات المتحدة ربما شجعت أيضًا
الرئيس التركي الذي رغب في شراء
صاروخ باتريوت.
لم يستطع
شرائها الآن ، لقد احتاجها للدفاع الذي كان يعرفه ،
لذلك ذهب بعد ذلك إلى روسيا ، لذا فقد
كانت هناك فوضى ، وبصراحة لم يكن
خطأها حقًا أن الحليفين كانا
في مسار تصادمي لسنوات مع
قائمة طويلة من  الخلافات بما في ذلك
الولايات المتحدة  كدعم للقوات الكردية السورية التي
تعتبرها أنقرة إرهابية ولكن
مع تسليم نظام أسلحة من
صنع عدو أمريكا
يأتي اختبارًا جديدًا وحقيقيًا للعلاقات التركية
الأمريكية.